Next question is about Joe Biden, Donald Trump
and Utah.
David, if Mitt Romney endorses Biden, could
Biden win Utah?
So the answer is no.
The short answer is no.
And the background for the question I understand
there was recently a poll that showed in very,
very right wing conservative Utah, Donald
Trump winning only by three points.
The idea about Mitt Romney is Mitt Romney
is a Republican senator from Utah.
Mitt Romney's Mormon.
Utah has a big Mormon population.
Mormons maybe what while disproportionately
Republican voters, they also may just follow
what Mitt Romney does.
If Mitt Romney says, hey, vote for Biden.
Could it turn Utah against Donald Trump?
I don't I don't see it.
I think the best case scenario would be if
Mitt Romney does endorse Joe Biden.
That it makes Utah so competitive that Trump
has to spend money there.
And then that means there's less money Trump
can spend in other places.
But the truth is that since the year 2000,
the only Democrat to carry more than 30 percent
even in Utah was Obama in 2008.
And he still lost like in other words, Democrats
often don't even get 30 in Utah.
And when Obama did, he still lost very, very
significantly.
The best we can hope for is that Mitt Romney
makes it a fight for Donald Trump.
And now there is one other thing to think
about here.
Imagine if Mitt Romney ran third party that
actually could take away enough from Trump
and Utah that it could play spoiler essentially,
and turn it over to Joe Biden.
But the problem is that if Mitt Romney ran
third party, he'd be running third party.
I don't think he would just run in Utah and
he would risk in places like Michigan and
Wisconsin and others giving the election potentially,
potentially to Donald Trump.
We just don't know.
It would be dicey and I would be worried about
it.
So I think the best thing job a Mitt Romney
can do is seems unlikely he's going to support
Donald Trump.
If he is going to support Joe Biden, just
say it.
And I think that that is all we can really
hope for and make Utah a fight, make Trump
spend some money.
You know, we talk about what's going on with
Amy Magrath and Mitch McConnell in that Senate
race in Kentucky.
I, I it's possible Amy McGrath could win.
It's an uphill battle.
In a recent poll, she was up one, but with
a huge number of undecideds and people not
yet really paying that much attention.
I hope she wins.
But even if she doesn't, if it's this close,
Republicans will probably have to funnel a
bunch of national money into Kentucky to defend
a seat that has historically been very, very
safe for Republicans.
That's still good, even if you don't end up
winning the seat.
So that's my take right now.
I don't think there's any real way that Joe
Biden wins Utah.
But let's make a Trump fight for it.
Why not?